So we're missing um like a few.
Gabriel? Oh no.. how are you dear?
Are you with us?
we're gonna take the 720 and I'm going
to try to point things out as we go
what the hell is going on here. So we are on Wilshire.
as we move east we enter into areas
which are not as wealthy
I can see parts of LA that I hadn't previously seen. Just a whole new experience.
Skid Row is there we're gonna go on the edges of it
because I don't want to be a kind of
tourist of misery
This is Union Station look here always
at the ceilings. We're going to see the
tremendous care that is done in this
roof. This was bustling with activity we
are going across which is Olvera
Street this is where the
Pueblo Los Angeles was born.
Before the music begins
again this is the oldest house existent
in Los Angeles it actually dates to 1818
when this was a still part of Spain
Chinatown is there unfortunately we
don't have enough time to do that
And all those people dressed in white are
being baptized. Ooh look at that one!
¡Que bonita!
[homelessness] moving up here
We should have crossed
we are going into the Cathedral of Our
Lady of Los Angeles a very controversial
architectural building. It does not fit
the kind of idea of what a Cathedral should
look like
I mean I've been all here but I don't
know the history behind it and that's
what the professor is for. oh yeah he's
really nice yeah funny
this is the Ahmanson
art complex
The Disney Concert Hall. Incredible acoustics
I have been coming
here for 20 years
the man was called Bradbury the owner
and a draftsman man in his firm supposedly
consulted a ouji board all kinds of
movies are filmed in this in this
building which is my favorite building
in LA
there is a room there where the Oscars took place for the first time
it's really nice, it's interesting to come
with the group and learn a little bit
more about the history
people say to me 'how do you know this?'
I am 250 years old
how many things do we have left?
let's do it
It's very immersive I feel like
I feel like an actual Angelino for once
we're going to see that there is a children's
library all the people who live in the
neighborhood come to the library with
the children and so on but I want to
show you this frescoes here
the ones on top are very interesting and quite
damning the missionaries arrive
the natives are delighted to see them can I
work for you they said there was
continuous genocide against the Native
Americans
but this is how you construct history
we left at 10 and we are going back
after five and still not enough time
what I want them to see is to see the
diversity of the city
the nature of this
ethnic and racial and linguistic
diversity. That diversity is creative
That diversity is something
that we should all embrace completely
and I believe that